if you've been watching esports for a
long time then you know that things used
to be pretty
[Music]
scuffed so we're here here at day four
the day that was never meant to happen
it is the extended world playoffs and as
you can see the construction is going on
behind us right now from extra days to
cancelled games to lag esports
broadcasting has never been
easy talking about this game though
let's go and take a look at champions
select because we saw a lot of mid lane
focus in terms of bands as well as pixel
oh there's a lot of us you know what
this is better let's just get on keep
that one up there oh there we go
so boring but during covid
things got
a lot worse so when we started on the
lpl feed we were going through vove
software kind of very similar to zoom we
were casting with no audio whatsoever so
no in-game audio and our 144p because
the signal has to go from china to us
and back and there's plenty of examples
from 2021 spring where
i don't know what i'm talking about
because i'm like i just see colors
there's no definitive shapes there's
just a color and i'm assuming it's this
champion you see it's one thing to
broadcast an esports event from a studio
or an arena with professional equipment
but it is another thing entirely to do
it from your bedroom but riot is trying
to change all that with a new 20 million
dollar studio in dublin ireland as part
of what they're calling project striker
there's never really been anything like
it in esports and it can do things no
other studio ever has i cannot tell you
how happy i was when i saw this place
and i did the tour here yesterday and i
was flawed it exceeded every expectation
that i possibly had so how did all of
this happen and more importantly if
you're just a viewer at home who's
either deeply or casually interested in
the future of riot esports
why should you care
[Applause]
okay so before we start talking about
project striker i just wanted to take a
second to actually thank both cisco and
riot games for sending one of our teams
out to dublin ireland to see this studio
we got to shoot b-roll and do interviews
and basically just capture the magic of
this thing so that we could bring it to
you the viewers this video would quite
literally have not been possible without
their help so thank you riot has
actually been broadcasting a lot of
their biggest events remotely for years
now from worlds to msi a lot of the
tournaments you've watched have featured
casters halfway or sometimes all the way
around the world but that hasn't always
been easy
in fact sometimes
it has been
a sh show
how's it going everybody welcome back to
the plans mark just wasn't ready for you
and even as league of legends casters
and broadcasting teams tried to iron out
the challenges of remote production
technical staff behind the scenes knew
that there was another challenge on the
horizon one that boasted some
particularly precise gun play the start
the idea the genesis of project striker
you have to actually go back to before
the pandemic we're in the what we call
it lab it's kind of our innovation lab
in our campus in los angeles and this is
before anyone outside of riot had seen
what would become our next game or
valerian i remember sitting there and
watching two of the engineers on the
team that i support put in hours i mean
like six hours straight of just playing
this pre-alpha build of what would
become valerian and i watched them get
really invested in this this new ip
and it kind of dawned on me
if this is good it's it's grabbing their
attention
what's going to happen if this becomes
an esport so riot's global head of
technology the homie scott adametz who
you may remember from our video about
the realm went to his boss a sir by the
name of john needham and proposed that
they spend
well a lot of money to fix this problem
then they got to work but there were a
lot of details to figure out and though
riot had run english broadcasts from
their studios in la and berlin it was
clear early on that they'd have to build
something new since the la studio needed
to continue to run the lcs and berlin
needs to continue to run the lec and so
on take the world carve it into three
eight hour shifts and then place a
production center strategically in each
of those time zones so now that unlocks
being able to produce in daylight hours
or as close to daylight hours and normal
time
per facility we call it follow the sun
where a production can start in one
locale transfer to the next and continue
and then transfer to the third before we
get back to the first but while riot was
still nailing out the details
covet hit
and the world
turned upside down suddenly the
broadcast teams trying to bring you your
favorite leagues had to work from home
casters went from working in a
state-of-the-art studio to their bedroom
and for some leagues like the lpl that
control room was halfway around the
world
where's the action penguin
oh well apparently i lost penguin which
i didn't know so oh lyric is back once
again with the solo cast i guess it
sounded like i was talking to no one
here's the thing though after bouncing
around from studios to home setups
around the globe for over two years of
pandemic
that lpl crew
got pretty good at it this is gonna
sound really weird but we had ender uh
christy fryerson over for 2021 summer
and he came over to me at one point
right towards the end of the remote
broadcasting put his hand on my shoulder
and goes you know what oshie it's not
that scuffed and then just walked away
so that was probably the nicest thing
i've had about the remote broadcasting
but when they were staring down the
prospect of going remote yet again this
spring
burnout
finally started to set in they knew they
wanted to get together for playoffs but
that because of china's tight coveted
restrictions there would be no feasible
way of it happening there unfortunately
it kind of got to a point where we were
running out of time to make a decision
and i just put my hand up in a meeting
and said
we can do this in my house and everyone
just kind of went can we i was like
maybe
maybe we can and eventually oshie was
just like hey look why don't you just
come to my house my
roommate is out i've got the whole
apartment here i've got it downstairs we
can use as the analyst desk the couch
can be set up there i've got full
casting equipment set up in the top
stairs we can actually all be in the one
spot and it all kind of just fell
together from there where i had some
equipment that i could bring with me and
munchables brought a whole bunch of his
gear with them as well and it meant that
we could actually between ourselves kind
of higgledy biggerly get enough bits
together so it could all work welcome
one and all to
my front room
i am using dagger ox we got this instead
of going yeah i'm super happy with it
it works it works functional we've
called out some of the stops
and look let's put some respect on these
guys they had to slap this whole thing
together by themselves with very little
outside tech support i sure as could not
do that
maybe colton good
it was an ordeal i will say uh but it
was very fun to kind of figure out what
is the
literally like the the bare bones of
like how do i make this work with as
much with as little professional
equipment as possible so
yeah casting over the past couple years
has ranged from scuffed to
arguably less scuffed the thing is riot
knew they had a solution
they just had to build it they chose
dublin as the first location thanks to
its convenient time zone location though
let's be honest i'm sure the steady
never-ending supply of dry stout
didn't hurt after sharing a few pints
they quickly got to work scouting
properties and the place they landed on
might not be what you'd expect you see
the property wasn't exactly famous for
its production space it was known for
having at one point the single largest
disco ball in europe for me it was
surreal so the studio itself used to be
of the ireland's biggest nightclub so i
used to go to that nightclub so go to
walking in and being like that's where i
ordered a drink that's where i met my
friend that's where he fell over it's a
very weird kind of surreal experience
but when we kind of got in here although
it was largely closed in from what you
see now is kind of like oh my god
there's an atmosphere that i really feel
could work so a lot of the atrium behind
us this was all closed in you've never
seen into the spaces
and i remember just coming in like no no
trust me i'm going to send you loads of
videos and photos and they were like
still don't get it and like i even think
just in the last few days of people
coming in here it's not until they walk
in they go oh my god i get it and then
things started to move
like really fast 29th of july we got the
keys and by the 10th of september we
were breaking ground so a lot of what we
had to front load know when we were
going through the leasing process was
make sure that we had the local planning
authorities and whatnot all lined up so
that we could
do the due diligence get them on board
and really hit the ground running once
we had the lease over the line the 20
million dollar transformation of the
space from nightclub to studio happened
in just six months with technology and
construction workers operating in the
same spaces at the same times now you
might be thinking
it's a studio dimitri right like
whoopty do it this is rido we're talking
about like surely they've constructed
plenty of cool looking broadcast rooms
before what exactly is project striker
why does it sound like something
straight out of metal gear and how can
one building even start to fix all of
these problems let's start with
connection you see traditionally esports
broadcasts have used this thing called
sdi to transmit sync signals
hold on i actually read up on this just
to spite colton don't cut away yet just
give me a chance to
gather my thoughts and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
wait what why am i even in this episode
you do know how many experts we
interviewed for this episode right
well
anyways sdi which stands for serial
digital interface is a type of physical
coaxial cable used to transmit video and
audio feeds for a production at some
pretty remarkable speeds over distances
that would make your run-of-the-mill
hdmi cable shutter but traditional
sports don't generally have most of
their production halfway around the
world from where the event is happening
every riot event essentially faces the
herculean task of setting up their
broadcast for something more akin to the
olympics that's why instead of the
typical setup riot decided to run
everything in their production studio
through an internal network using
something called spineleaf architecture
that would allow everything in the
studio to run over these guys
or fiber
or direct attached copper but
i don't have either of those we actually
talked a bit about this in our episode
about why streamers will sometimes use
two pcs but this this is in a whole
different universe pumping all these
high bandwidth audio and video feeds
over a purpose-built internal network is
one thing but once you introduce a
signal coming from countries away over
the internet things can get a little
dicey riot thanks in no small part to
cisco built what is in essence their own
isp just to help tackle this problem and
with the help of some fancy new video
codecs and
all right look i might know what i'm
talking about but i'm gonna let the
actual experts handle the rest okay and
that was the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about it was a big risk and
something that other broadcasters are
honestly
still not really all that ready to do
but when it came together
man that
was fast we just did an event in
singapore where we were transmitting
signals from singapore to dublin the
path we took was across the pacific the
united states and the atlantic so they
were going two-thirds of the way around
the world and we were still able to get
return signals to singapore in about a
third of a second you could sit there
and watch a graphic animate on the stage
and a split second later you would see
that animation come back on the screen
for a lot of broadcasters that's normal
you're used to seeing that level of
delay but that's just to the truck and
back on site it's not going from
singapore to dublin and back it's the
first time you know i've seen anything
like that and and honestly this is miles
ahead of anything that anyone's doing in
traditional broadcast i saw that shot
and i was just like my heart was racing
so broadcasts won't have the kind of
massive signal delays we experienced
during the pandemic but just in case
right now is the time you're starting to
you know nod off a little bit riot
direct is more than just speedy signals
it will actually make your games yes you
your games run better ride direct is
entirely powered by cisco and it has got
hundreds of points of presence all over
the world and terabits of edge capacity
we are a small user the bigger user is
the games riot built that because the
way that our game actually functions uh
it's the first type of traffic to be
dropped is the type of traffic that our
games utilize there's a reason for that
it makes the game better so riot built
this isp
to be able to say to other isps around
the world give us our traffic destined
for our game servers we'll protect it
and it'll get it off of your network
which frees you up to do more netflix
streaming or whatever whatever they're
whatever they're doing
we'll protect that traffic all the way
to the game server and back we're
actually tapping into that network here
and in all the other facilities and
through a new technology called jpeg xs
feeds going out to any remote staff will
be visually lossless meaning we won't
see any 140p
casting feeds that play-by-plays can't
decipher but why should you
you sitting there at home care about
this flashy new studio well striker
isn't all behind the scenes so when
person at home starts to watch shows
that come through this facility you'll
actually start to see more things added
to productions that traditionally we
wouldn't we wouldn't be able to fit or
wouldn't be able to had to make choices
and concessions we don't have to do that
anymore so i'm the most excited to see
what comes next in augmented reality
mixed reality environments and then
the idea that resolution is no longer a
limit for us we don't have to be in
1080p
4k is it's 2022 we should be doing this
in 4k and the best part about being a
esports company is our games can render
in whatever resolution we want them to
so 8k is not that far off and what
exactly do we mean by ar well if you
aren't a died in the wool league fan who
remembers the elder dragon at worlds
2017 it's actually been showing up more
and more in esports ar is a big portion
of our shows it's augmented reality what
we do with that is we bring elements
that you can't see in the real world but
that integrate with production
seamlessly so when you watching the
broadcast you can see a character from
the game
on stage or you can see certain elements
it doesn't have to be you know a
rendered image it's almost like another
piece of the stage that's not really
there now dublin is the first of three
striker studios they're in construction
on a warehouse in seattle right now and
there will be a third location somewhere
in asia that they're still scouting and
the bottom line is that
we don't really know what the future
holds but there's no question that
project striker represents a massive
investment by riot in the future with
help from cisco's technology we've gone
from early esports broadcasts held
together with duct tape and faith to a
20 million dollar state of the art
production studio one that will help
solve years of challenges and make
remote broadcasting possible from
virtually anywhere with big games in
development in a bunch of genres striker
could set them up for splashy
productions across a range of titles
including ones we haven't really seen
before and if you're someone who just
loves esports
that's pretty cool
[Applause]
i uh fun fights i actually won the
when it was at night
did you actually
that's crazy i'm sure you told them that
when you went there you left the part
out that the last time you were there
you were physically shoving a man
screaming you you won't knight boy
thanks brother
thank you
thanks thanks for the cheeky guinnesses
loves